amc has put out more than its fair share
of hit television shows in the past
several years
but the undisputed cornerstone of the
network remains the walking dead
debuting on october 31st 2010 the
program
offered a dramatic new spin on the
zombie genre by putting the focus on the
human survivors
and their lives with one another and
using the reanimated masses
which aren't even called zombies in the
show as a backdrop this approach made
the series a pop culture phenomenon in
no time
and propelled it for over a decade while
the walking dead is immensely popular
it isn't exactly a show that's
accessible to everyone
the collapse of modern society and the
rise of flesh-hungry corpses known as
walkers are enough to turn off viewers
who are sensitive to such content
factor in the excessive blood gore and
general violence that constantly follow
the characters
elaborate special effects that make
death scenes look far too real
and the series use of well-timed jump
scares and you've got a recipe for a
show
that is just too much for some people
for the majority of walking dead viewers
this content comes with a territory and
there are no complaints to be had
however there are a few odd scenes that
unsettled even the most
committed fans and many have confessed
that a few walking dead moments
went way too far we here at looper were
curious about the walking dead fandom's
picks
for its most stomach churning scenes we
polled viewers and according to our
results
almost 28 of respondents agreed that
negan smith
brutally killing glenn rhee and abraham
ford
was the hardest moment to handle for
those who don't recall in the season 7
premiere
ominously and aptly entitled the day
will come when you won't be negan taunts
rick grimes and his group of fellow
survivors
who he has ordered to kneel on the
ground and declare their loyalty to him
he chooses abraham to make an example on
using his barbed wire
covered bat lucille to bludgeon him in
the head
when daryl dixon attempts to take a
stand and attack negan
the bat-wielding maniac has a simple
response
that oh my
that is a no-no
then of course things go from bad to
worse negan decides that the group needs
to be further punished
and he selects glenn as his next victim
he kills him without mercy
in the same way that he did to abraham
the brutal deaths of glenn and abraham
have been remembered in
infamy and even one of the walking dead
stars
involved in the scene thought it went
too far during an appearance on the talk
dead to me podcast
abraham actor michael cutlins revealed
his true feelings
i always think it was a bridge too far
personally
i thought it was too much either one of
us should have lived a little bit longer
because people were very affected by it
cutlets added that he knows more
gruesome deaths
happened in the walking dead but glenn
and abraham's
struck viewers because they truly cared
about the characters
there were a lot of other killings and
murders and lives lost on the show that
were a lot more brutal but the fact that
i think you loved abraham and glenn so
much as an audience that's what makes it
more brutal
unsurprisingly for a show as gory as the
walking dead
negan's bloody executions weren't
totally unopposed in our poll about
which scenes went too far
the season 3 episode killer within also
ranks high
it deals with the death of rick's wife
laurie who had to undergo an emergency
c-section
courtesy of maggie green to save her
baby that gut-wrenching scene culminates
with lori and rick's son
carl killing his mom before she returns
as a walker
from there the pics don't get any less
heartbreaking
the runners-up include rick killing
sophie in her walker form in front of
her mom
along with carol shooting the severely
disturbed lizzie
and finally noah's demise at the hands
of a zombie horde rounds out the list
with more than 150 episodes to look back
on
this is surely just the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to the show
testing the limits of cable television
guidelines
now that its historic run will wrap up
in 2022
one has to wonder if the walking dead
will try to push the envelope one more
time
or have mercy on its fans and give us a
hopeful ending
either way it's going to be tough to say
goodbye to the show
and all its surviving characters it's an
emotional moment
i get it check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one